donald trump
a man whose presidential library could
conceivably exhibit a razzie award
seriously he won a razzie in 1991
for his supporting role in the film
ghosts can't do it
as a businessman negotiating with bo
derek in this room there are knives
sharp enough to cut you to the bone
and hearts cold enough to eat yours as
hors d'oeuvres
you're too pretty to be bad
that kissy face is the single most
disgusting thing that's ever been in a
movie
and i'm very much including the human
centipede
but look we're not going to talk about
trump's movie career tonight instead we
want to focus on the two-year
anniversary of one of his signature
campaign promises
we are going to drain the swamp in
washington d.c
it's time to drain the swamp of
corruption drain the
swamp look at that sign drain the swamp
we're gonna drain the swamp of
washington we're gonna have fun doing it
we're all doing it together
wait we're gonna have fun doing it and
we're all doing it together sounds less
like a campaign promise and more like a
nervous host
rambling through the introduction of
their first ever orgy so
we're going to have fun doing it and
we're all doing it together and thanks
for the hummus spread tom oh we
said no names didn't we uh
dominique dominic domini everybody
now mind the coffee table
and look look limiting the power of
industry lobbyists and special interests
is a genuinely good idea
and while i would love to give him
credit the odds are if your whole
political platform is just
screaming random three-word phrases one
of them is gonna bound to end up being
good
lock her up no build the wall no all dog
zoo
stop that's actually a great idea it
took a while but you finally threw out a
good one
and while trump by no means came up with
that phrase it clearly caught
on after he won because other candidates
began using it and perhaps
not more memorably or literally than
this guy
i'm bob gray an outsider and a
businessman
i'm running to fuel the economy choke
off wasteful spending
and secure our nation but most
importantly
i promise to drain the swamp
i'm bob gray conservative republican and
i approve this message
right except you're not really draining
the swamp so much as you are
moving it a couple of feet off camera
and
and scooch the swamp it just doesn't
quite have the same ring to it does it
but as much as people have taken to
trump's drain the swamp
promise it won't remotely surprise you
to know that he has not drained the
swamp even one little bit
his capita has included many swamp
creatures from these two goldman sachs
veterans working on tax policy
gary cohn and certified handful of man
candy steve mnuchin
to wilbur ross commerce secretary
wealthy corporate raider and living
worst-case scenario what can happen when
wallace shaun is not stored at the
proper temperature
now trump trump has a laughable number
of wealthy businessmen presiding over
policies that could directly benefit
themselves
and their former employers and
incredibly despite drain the swamp being
one of trump's greatest hits at his
rallies
many of his supporters do not seem
troubled by this
the swamp is horrible and trump is there
he's there for the small guy he's there
for people like myself
though his cabinet is filled with
multi-millionaires i love that
they're not politicians and you don't
see them as part of the swamp who have
capitalized on the system
in in in in a capitalist system
you're allowed to make money being rich
is
good yeah so then what is the swamp the
swamp for me
the mainstream is is it it is yes you
almost nail it
it's the mainstream it's the elites that
look down
on a small guy like myself okay first
if you're mainstream you can't be elite
by definition elites are a select group
superior to the mainstream those terms
are mutually exclusive digging into this
logical fallacy makes me sound like an
elitist
it does not make me sound like a
mainstream do you see what i
mean but the second second
and perhaps most importantly the narrow
question of self-enrichment is only
part of why the swamp is a problem a
much bigger issue is the
harm that can that it can actually do
and that is what our story is about
tonight
because real damage is being done to the
small guy
by this administration's actions take
payday lending as we've discussed on the
show before people's lives can be
destroyed
by misleadingly marketed high interest
loans but the new acting head of the
consumer financial protection bureau
mick mulvaney has been actively working
with the payday loan industry
to block rules reigning them in why
would he do that
i don't know what i do know is that as a
congressman he got sixty thousand
dollars in campaign contributions
from payday lending interests and
earlier this year he told a room full of
bankers this amusing anecdote
we had a hierarchy in my office in
congress if you're a lobbyist who never
gave us money
i didn't talk to you if you're a
lobbyist who gave us money
i might talk to you now he did say he
would always talk to constituents
whether they gave him money or not but
the fact molly he's admitting
that as a lobbyist money might get you a
meeting
you don't often hear that from a
politician yeah
you actually don't i mean it's something
that everyone naturally assumes but it
is weird to hear it out loud it's like a
disney world park attendant saying hey
kids
who almost have their photo taken with a
30 year old theater major who couldn't
hack it in the industry and who now
wears a full body mouse suit
i mean there's no new information there
but it is still unpleasant to listen to
but just focusing on the famous
alligators in trump's swamp
is missing some of the most important
damage that is getting done
by lesser-known bureaucrats and to
illustrate that let's look at two
agencies tonight first the epa now for a
year
it was run by scott pruitt who became a
household name for doing things like
spending
forty thousand dollars on a soundproof
booth in his office
trying to get the ceo of chick-fil-a to
give his wife a franchise
and demanding an expensive 24-7 security
detail then making it
drive him around town to see which ritz
carlton had the lotion he likes
which is simply insane because everyone
knows the best lotion comes from
la quinta inn that's right if you want
to masturbate with hotel lotion
choose lakita it's like their slogan
says
la quinta has the lotion that will help
you jeez
now once once pruitt left there were not
as many flashy headlines about the epa
but that itself
is actually dangerous because he was not
an isolated case nearly half of the
political appointees hired by trump at
the epa
have strong industry ties and the guy
who replaced pruitt
is not much of an improvement the man
tapped to be pruitt's replacement
andrew wheeler a man who forbes says
earned more than
thousand dollars in recent years as wait
for it
a coal lobbyist yeah at this point
though cnn you really don't need to ask
the american people to
wait for it surprise is just one more
emotion that trump has completely
destroyed along with joy
wonder and the ability to see someone
wearing a red hat from behind without
mentally saying
god damn it
now now as as a coal lobbyist
wheeler pushed hard to roll back
environmental regulations impacting the
industry in fact here he is
as a lobbyist meeting with rick perry
doing exactly that
and little over a year later he is
running the epa
and dismantling the very regulations he
lobbies against which is ridiculous
it's like handing your city's waste
management over to a seagull
so let me get this straight the new
strategy is we just throw our trash
everywhere
and leave it strewn around and we should
have more french fries in our garbage
how the are you in charge but but
wheeler
wheeler is actually a really good
example of how
once trump's swamp starts seeping in it
can filter all the way down
an organization and for just how deep it
can go simply look at the department of
the interior
on this show we've lavished quite a bit
of attention on trump's appointee to
head them
ryan zinke which is understandable he
rode a horse to work on his first day at
the department
he swung karen pence around like a bag
of potatoes
and despite the fact that he is very
much not a geologist
he has a weird habit of doing this
that's the question i asked and i'm a
geologist
i'm a geologist i'm a geologist i'm a
geologist i'm a geologist
he's not a geologist at all
besides bragging about being a geologist
is a very
weird boast it's just behind walking
around saying i own crackers
saltines cheez-its you name it i own it
not oyster crackers of course who am i
bill gates
zinke has also taken 66 personal days in
his first year and a half on the job and
has been the subject of no less than 15
investigations
and reportedly he may actually be gone
any day now but even if that happens
serious problems will remain because the
swamp runs deep
interior is a massive department and
there is real power at
every level i'll show you look at this
organizational chart
below zinke and the deputy secretary and
the assistant secretary for land and
minerals management you will find a very
important subdivision
called the bureau of safety and
environmental enforcement or bessie
which is in charge of safety on offshore
oil rigs i don't know what you're
thinking
safety on offshore oil rigs wouldn't
regulatory oversight of any resource
development on the outer continental
shelf fall under the jurisdiction of the
minerals management service
would wouldn't that be where the
responsibility lies john to which i say
congratulations on being a sex
god and you know what you're right
you're right
the minerals management service actually
used to be in charge of safety
until 2010 when there was that
catastrophe at deepwater horizon
this is the video bp did not want the
world to see
a toxic blend of oil and gas spewing
from its broken well at the bottom of
the gulf of mexico
yes the deepwater horizon famously
pumped over 130 million gallons of oil
into the gulf of mexico about 12 times
the size of the exxon valdez spill
costing the region billions and badly
hurting the fishing and tourism
industries and you know you know it was
a disaster
because mark wahlberg made a movie about
it
and he usually chooses his starring
films about the most absolutely
appalling things
stuff like tragic shipwrecks acts of
terrorism
and mel gibson's seamless reintegration
into hollywood
and and years years after deporter
horizon
the region was still feeling the effects
when the little boats fish in this area
right here
powerful what they catch is the form
really half half
and what kind of deformities they got
tumors on the head little bumps off the
side it's all in the gills where they
breathe at
sit all in there yeah so that's oil in
these gills
yeah if you take this shell off you
could pull the oil out you could smell
it
yeah that's horrible not only did that
spill devastate an economy it somehow
actually managed to make shrimp
even more disgusting and i hate shrimp
they are slimy armored alien bugs for
whom proper preparation involves
pulling out their bane there is not
enough cocktail sauce in the world
to erase the memory of a vein and
yet somehow
that oil spill made them even grosser
now now before
deepwater horizon the minerals
management service was in charge of both
safety on oil rigs
and collecting revenues from oil
companies which was clearly
a bad idea because it was an obvious
conflict of interest so
after deep water they created bessie an
agency whose only job
is to keep people and the environment
safe that is their sole
responsibility promotion of drilling in
the gulf that is someone else's job
bessie's is safety that is all they do
that is probably why its last two heads
were a former coast
guard officer specializing in marine
safety and a former coast guard officer
specializing in marine safety however
trump has taken
a different path appointing scott angel
former lieutenant governor of louisiana
and a guy who is aggressively pro
drilling
for a sense of just how aggressive he is
just days after the deep water well was
capped
angel was at a rally organized by the
louisiana oil and gas association
where he called for an immediate
resumption of deep sea drilling
saying this enough is enough
and it's time to quit punishing innocent
american workers
to achieve some unrealistic political
agenda
while we too support the use of
renewable
and alternative energy let's keep the
conversation real
america is not yet ready to get all of
its fuel from the birds and the bees and
the flowers and the trees
hold on hold on america is not yet ready
to get fuel from trees
you mean wood scientists have understood
how wood works for years now
maybe even decades but after serving as
lieutenant governor angel joined the
board of sunoco logistics partners and
oil pipeline company earning nearly a
million dollars
and now he's regulating the oil industry
and if there is
any doubt about his priorities which
there is not
just wait until you see something we
found on youtube because last year
angel gave a presentation at an oil
industry conference where he was flanked
by two men
one in a hard hat both of whom were
eating during a significant portion of
his speech
but that is not the important part the
incredible moment
is when he makes it painfully clear
exactly how accessible he
the man in charge of enforcing safety
remember is willing to be
to industry leaders my cell number
is anybody wants to
give me a call to talk about it my cell
number is 571-585-3730
571-585-3730
i'd rather you call me everything you
texted me is a public record so be
careful this is a business
uh opportunity for you to engage with me
on what you believe
uh we ought to be about holy
he just gave out his work cell phone
number and encouraged oil bosses to call
him on it as a business opportunity
that is outrageous for two reasons first
because he's doing that to avoid the
public record
and second no one should ever call
rather than text
i don't care what the scenario is if you
prefer calling
to texting you're a psychopath
and you should be put in prison
forever your text detects whatever the
situation
and and that is his real number we know
because we called it
and apparently he gives it out publicly
to executives all the time
at another industry conference he even
announced it from a stage
and who knows what those executives tell
him it's not part of the public record
but by sheer coincidence he's urged the
white house to loosen safety
requirements implemented in the wake of
deepwater horizon
which they are now planning to do and
which is estimated could save oil
companies
nearly a billion dollars over the next
decade
which is the most shocking 10 digit
number i've heard
since 571.58 37
30. so it seems pretty clear at this
point
that trump has in no way drains the
swamp
what he has done is drained the phrase
of its original meaning and in fairness
to him
he was pretty transparent from the
beginning about how little he meant it
this is him just one month after his
election essentially telling everyone to
their faces
that the phrase was meaningless funny
how that term caught on isn't it
i told i tell everybody i hated it
somebody said drain the swamp i said oh
that's so hokey
that is so terrible i said all right
i'll try it
so like a month ago i said drain the
swamp place went crazy i said whoa watch
this then i said it again then i started
saying it like i meant it right
and then i said it i started loving it
and the place loved it strained the
swamp i mean it's true
it's true it's true
it isn't it isn't it isn't
trump never meant to drain the swamp and
you can tell that by what has happened
since
because he promised to clean up dc and
instead the guy in charge of the cfpb
is holding hands with loan sharks the
epa might as well be run by a sentient
piece of coal
and is head of oil rig safety wants the
industry to blow up his digits like an
under-regulated oil well
all in all it seems like if there is
anyone remaining who is still hoping
that trump might drain the swamp
you can now officially kissy face that
idea goodbye
you